what's up everybody it's your boy Travis
with 12 talks back at it again with
another week
uh talking about what happened over the
weekend Sports everything how y'all day
going man lay out like my new onesie
got my new onesies
the shoes check out the new kicks
sir
the onesie man the ones that bro
all right
all right if you already get started
because we can get started right away
yeah once you go crazy this time huh
[Music]
yeah sir
appreciate I will get healthy
[Music]
we got next coach told
Taylor Rooks about my game day text I
want to talk about one of your other
Colorado Sons for a minute Travis Hunter
um yeah I mean first off when you say
his name it's just like he's so he's him
good he's him he's him in every bit in
every aspect he is him like we have
never seen someone like Travis and you
won't Travis loves the game
loves to prepare loves to study he's in
love with the process of it and a lot of
people that
are projected the way he's projected
ain't they just want it to be that guy
and they relied on
the story
to be told in them not working towards
it Travis wanted I think at 5 30 or 6
a.m every game day morning I get a text
let's go
and so we played the night game so last
week he was late he was like came about
nine I say you late
let's go
he said I know he was tired I just
wanted you to sleep in yeah
I did this for you yeah but I I love him
to life yeah and he is
I love my coach man so complete as a
player even as a person Travis don't
care about no jewelry Travis don't care
about no high priced cars Travis want to
fish want to play video games want to
spend time with his his girlfriend and
want to be the best that he can be
that's who Travis is he's really
he's like Dion really he's like him he
really is in so many aspects yeah man
every morning game day ritual you know
text my coach
probably like 5 30. I'll probably get up
at 5 15. wait a couple minutes brushing
teeth
you know get on your phone for a little
second then I text him let's go you know
I'm ready by that time I mean football
days football games bro game days I
can't sleep in I can't sleep for nothing
I try to go to sleep
just don't happen
but yeah I do that man every day yeah
like you said I don't like jewelry I
don't like flashy cars I'm just so
simple I like to fish
play football play video games
that's pretty much it and chill with my
girlfriend all day that's
one thing I like doing the most man is
those things right there oh yeah the
video got out about me telling coach
prom I want to go back on the field this
week I need to play this week we need to
get everything we can so I can get down
the field I'm not taking no
who you think sent me that
how did you know that
because what
no you ain't ready and I care about your
boy and I care about this game you're
going to change the game of football one
day when you help them ready the future
is brighter than mine ever will be It
Ever Was relax and get healthy I love
you son that was the conversation
I care about y'all more care about this
game but I want you to learn throughout
this game and through our trials and
tribulations Who You Are
yeah man I'm texting that bro
it's just hard seeing my my teammates my
brothers go out there
work and then I know I'm just a missing
piece at the end of the day just it's
just hard I mean I love playing with
them guys and I mean we we've been
through it all we've been through summer
all the people hating on us doubting us
people want to hop on the bandwagon
after we win a couple games then when we
lose we get more hate there's a lot of
people always hating and that is the
part that get me the most is I can't be
out there in like go ahead and dominate
so we won't have no excuses
so people won't have nothing to say I
mean I just like going out there and
playing at the end of the day helping my
team become the best team we we came
here to do we came here to be and that's
pretty much
like all I gotta say for that man I love
team to death man I know one of the top
one of the cabinets one of the top dogs
man
I know without me it's kind of hard for
them to Just Adjust in one week not even
a couple days
so
it is and there's a lot of people that's
hating bro we don't care about y'all
hating y'all go what are you getting out
of Haiti
Yeah it's you're not getting enough of
it we don't care you can hate all you
want it's just go it's gonna it's just
gonna make us go out there and fight
harder bro
people that hate and just dare to hate
just you how are you happy to see
somebody lose I don't get that
you're happy to see somebody lose if you
if you don't want to see us on social
media stop going on social media
just literally all you have to do it's
not that hard but we're happy y'all hey
because I don't do nothing but make us
want to prove y'all more wrong wrong so
that's how it is
a lot of people asking about my recovery
hey man just know when it's time for me
to go I'll be ready to go yeah that's
pretty much it for that recovery I'll
get it when it's time to get it if we
had a team
um organs field got a lot of attention
uh what you want me to say
all right I don't know what's going on I
wasn't there
but it's always gonna be hate man I
don't know what to tell y'all bro a lot
of people is gonna hate just to hate
don't get nothing out of it I guess they
just like the hate so
God don't like ugly just remember that
ones he's tough I know and I had I
stepped on my ones again I got a lot
more coming a lot more more in my pack
you know what I'm saying I got a lot
more
you go my shoes too bro
yeah got shoes to match it
yeah I'm always gonna be me appreciate
it
what's your favorite NFL team 49ers huge
problem man I will
I'm always gonna stay focused man the
hate don't get to me bro I just look at
it and laugh
a lot of people that hate having played
football ever
don't know anything about football they
just have favorite teams
so it's just funny to me man you know
the losers
they need and slash more attention
you're right
river or lake fishing lake fishing I
went fishing this morning called me some
small mouth bass video dropping soon the
49ers that sound like I've been working
I've been liking the 49ers since I
started playing football sorry brother
you screaming tonight Drive
I might hop on the screen
what's the story behind db3 underscore
tip there's no meaning behind it it's
just something that I well we thought of
in high school so I just kept it my
nickname is tip two worship twitch
db3 on this go tip Daryl rocking with
you appreciate it man you're going to be
course on Nuggets game uh no I don't
like I don't spend my money in those
type of ways
all right chat we're gonna get back to
y'all and the Ducks decided to dress up
as coach prom
thank you
his head came off
hey man I don't know what to say about
that I mean hey
they knew not to talk before that's all
that's all I could say they went into
the game to talk so
yeah
they did what they did they had the duck
dress it back up prime time it's funny
looking those dude got some hard
uniforms because London thinking we're
in it for clicks
laughs
well that's funny substance not flash
rooted in substance today
right every moment
the Cinderella story is over man right
they're fighting for clicks we're
fighting for wins there's a difference
right there's a difference right this
game ain't gonna be playing hello
[Music]
he knew the camera's in there he ain't
seen nothing all week and then he said
something game day hey we let him we let
him
hey bro we don't care about people
talking
because Leonard is a good coach I still
I still think so he recruited me when
he's at Georgia he had a great guy to me
so hey
he he did he found somewhere to fire his
team up and that's what he did Coach
Brown kept a real after the game
uh it translates in practice it is I
don't say stuff just to say it for a
click you know uncontrared to what
somebody say but uh yeah I keep her six
uh
but I'm serious I analyze and I
understand what we're up against and
what we have and what we need one thing
I could say honestly and candidly
you better get me right now
this is the worst we're gonna be
somebody yeah I got Messengers
God bless him though man he's a great
coach he's done a great job God bless
him he can take these shots he won I
don't shoot I don't do that they won
sample and yeah I never heard us put no
team in our mouth we don't
take shots out of the teams bro we take
the shots and keep it pushing be like
that you people other teams just get
phases that's personal posting on clips
and stuff right we don't talk about
nobody
that's what we have going on it's so
funny how everybody is focused on us
like other teams are focused on us hey
bro
we just do what we do best
ones he feels so good bro y'all just
don't know I just don't feel bro
I feel good man
and it fit right
but who played tonight the end of the
double hitter tonight Eagles Buffs
bucks equals bucks bucks
Eagles Bus Around Spangled so oh there's
some good football on tonight boss
we ran into some real company look what
happened bro do you play football that's
what I want to know
there's always people talking that don't
play football you're literally sitting
on the couch watching us like bruh
that was so funny y'all just come here
just to talk mess do y'all play football
yeah I do I ignore that man it just be
so funny just looking at them talk if I
play a college basketball well position
when I play point guard what's the
biggest fish I've called nine pounds
I did not play football okay then so why
are you talking
I play football on the skill level is
way different okay then when I get to
fit Amazon
man I need a onesie and IO bro I always
Rock onesies though not even just the
screaming I rock them all day when I'm
in the house talk is cheap yeah I know
the 2K screen this weekend we're fun to
watch yes sir I'm gonna get back on
screen
uh Friday fit appreciate it man all
right we done talking about the game
let's look at some funny moments from
this weekend
I just threw up like a hole
or throw up like what
if I ignore you're coming I mean you're
just talking about nothing
would you rather onesie to campus no I
can't coach prom would never let me do
nothing like that that's not even
professional like
the word I saw it keep it in the house
bro sometimes I just be wishing I could
just like
cut all y'all out of the chat that be
talking about nonsense
all right Jim official Miss tackle
yeah you're just standing in a way he
thought they had the first down or
something in it
fumble six that's what that was
number six
hey bro
yeah a whole pool of throw up bro it's
crazy
coach shows whatever replay on phone
what's your dream car TRX
drunk
I don't even think that's legal bro
that's funny though
we can't talk bass fishing right now bro
we got a whole script we gotta go
through first
we could talk bass fishing after this
Clemson water bottle stuck in helmet
dang water boy
how you do that
nah they tripping
now it's time for overreaction not a
reaction
the title says that oh let's get it
right into it
just fish Just Fish I want to get into
handle
I'll stay another damn was the game of
the year
I don't know about Game of the Year so
early
but it definitely was a good game
I was watching it
it was good it was a good game
overreaction though wasn't a game of the
year but it was a good game though
I feel like it's gonna be more good
games
he's kicking for the first time in years
it's hard
not an overreaction I'm pretty sure that
junk is hard
I can't even kick a football I could do
everything else but I cannot kick a
field goal
yeah that's hard
but I think it's hard bro
good prom deserve an Oscar oh I seen
this bro
hello yo I'm in a booth I'm gonna call
you right back no I just gotta put this
one part down I'm gonna call you back
I'm at the studio man how'd it worked
you know I actually like that but listen
I heard the news
[Music]
I don't know I don't play I'm a coach
now now for real don't play like that
you're playing the halftime show you
deserve this are you serious
how you know I'm coach friend and coach
Brian is always one step ahead and this
is your moment put that on everything
remember
when you look good you feel good when
you feel good you dance good when you
dance good and you say good you get to
play on the world's largest things
damn
I'm gonna call you back
You're Gonna Go imma call you back
deserves the Oscar yes sir not an
overreaction
but it's kind of easy though let's be
real punting yes easy but kicking the
field goal no
pressure you talking about pressure
getting a field goal to win the game too
that's so much pressure bro if I win the
game winning touchdown
pressure take catching the game winning
Pick pressure a lot of pressure
song I don't have a favorite song I
barely even listen to music cold weather
and human weather cold weather
I could deal with the cold
hey chat
I got that zesty
oh my bad my bad I got a zesty though
you know I keep the zesty on me
appreciate it bro
I'm trying to get back on the field as
soon as possible
as soon as the doctors let me go I'm
gonna not fear no stop
trying to get on that video but I build
a solid on Saturday yes sir
let's all be at the game
next up we got a blur let's look at some
of the best head tops this weekend
see this is a good game too blue
blue on his head to win the game it's
crazy that's crazy
to win the game man
top
Keon Coleman been going crazy this year
definitely I've been going crazy every
game
blue he blurred him and he didn't even
jump that's crazy
you got blurry without even jumping
um
he cut off the rebound
that's a good catch
oh I seen this blur
they ain't got smacked but he just
snagged that boy I ain't gonna lie
uh I ain't gonna lie that boy snack that
he snagged that boy
yep
was it a ob obj catch in in the game
maybe been an obj cash though that by
the drunk stuff
but we got next
[Music]
on his head
dang it he holding bruh
see bro that's a receiver I hate when
DB's whole
even that DB but I don't even try to I
don't even hold bro because it's like
bro I know what they go through when you
hold them bro like come on dog this is
so pointless why are you holding
no point of holding bruh
being be at the right place at the right
time if I'm holding
have a great week young man appreciate
it man I will
they blessed up
looking forward to seeing you back
on the field appreciate it I will be
back on the field as soon as possible
sooner they let me on that field I'm
gonna get back on that field and get
back right you know how that go how am I
feeling I'm feeling good man how are you
feeling how's your day going thank you
for asking feel great man what's your
Chick-fil-A order uh
get me like a 12 count nuggets meal with
a cookies and cream shake
with some zesty
there's some ketchup that's it
all right now let's get into housing
loading
you know what we do here
it's my list
my opinion nobody else's list and number
four
Junior
uh yes sir
number three
Caleb Williams
and number two shador Sanders
even though he had a not a great game
but hey still on top of my list and we
gonna do better each and every week
we're gonna get better that's what it's
about and number one
is me
when I get better you don't see a
different dog trust me I'm coming out
different now
I ain't got no time to waste can't play
around trying to go straight to work
what do I think about Texas Longhorns I
don't know
I won't be watching that the schools for
real man yeah shout out D strong for
that pick right down the wall man
yeah D got me right
Dolphins score 70 points oh my God
yeah 70 points is crazy
yeah that's great to work you know how
they go
what does a lactulated liver feel like I
don't know bro I just don't just hurt
non-stopping pain you can't even
describe a pan bro it just hurt
hopping in my mind off injury uh talking
to my girlfriend eating a lot of food
watching a lot of TV playing the game
screaming fishing yeah yeah
that's it all right before we get out of
here we're gonna talk about the upcoming
home game against USC
hopefully we can get back on track now
hey like I said last week bro it's not
about them it's about us we got to go
out there play our game we got to come
Focus
ready to dominate gotta get back
we gotta get back on track there's no
influence and Buzz about it we got to go
out there and dominate do what we can do
and
hey we just got a goddamn win that's
pretty much it
that's all you got to do is win
where I get my onesie from uh
Amazon
[Music]
we got to go go out there and win man
that's what that's
all it's about got a guardian dominate
perform well
can't hurt yourself feel like we heard
ourselves last game too much and that's
what we're gonna do we can't go out
there and hurt ourselves
so that's what we got to do that's how
we gotta come out win this game get
focused be ready to dominate take all
the mental mistakes from last week out
and
you're right
appreciate y'all man
I'm never going to be a man I am bro I'm
just still a kid at the same time
appreciate y'all for tuning in for
today's shows it's your host Travis
Hunter
12 talks and we out
see ya what I want to be yeah
[Music]
foreign